foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do
hi rebecca hi mark
are you this morning oh bored
just genuinely bored what's going on
nothing i've been walking for hours i i
found this one outfit eight hours of
work
this guy tried to cross my ass last
night it was kind of hot all night and
two days ago i saw mary kate wilson
i'm living in a hellhole of you smart
nothing's happening this pandemic is
running it's [ __ ] course why is the
girlfriend so boring
every other cookie is open why are you
in a very different mood this morning
you're all wound up oh i just i feel
like a teenager today what what vitamins
did you take last night i took some
kalonapin and some bonapan a little
vitamin c
let's call it molly i took some maury i
did a line of
molly mdma because there's nothing else
to do in life work the clubs are all
closed the kids are all dead and
hollywood
is better off than madden
how are you doing maureen i'm all right
good to hear
that's good to you do you ever take a
sip of my water go ahead thank you
i like what you're wearing today
uh what do you think i feel a little
basic but it's the best out of all my
outfits it's the most me what is that
it's a little proudest like a little
shift dress um it's kind of silky i
picked up next to trashcan this i picked
up on a sleeping person and this other
jacket had to grab from someone's pile
and run about a mile and a half afraid
they were attacking people i grabbed you
from the house how much of your daily
existence is
uh oh unboxing so
robbery is a robbery is the entirety of
my day due to my um
lifestyle as a pariah people don't give
me money because of the fact that i wear
skirts
and i'm very pleased and say god bless
you can i have a dollar for some soda
it's let's just ask for someone to buy
you food they always do like money
i don't want twenty dollars of [ __ ]
tacos for my tacos fan i'd rather 30
dollars smoke someone uh pizza from
spago but you're broke
um
someone's literally larceny i'm
committing pure larceny i steal my
clothes i steal my food next to my water
i see things in one pile so i just grab
them this is how i survive more what do
you worry about do you worry about
anything nothing i worry about like
getting bored or going to sleep mainly
going to sleep to me is almost like
after five days or five hours
my body is so tired from because i walk
i'm a nomad or some [ __ ] so you'll stay
up for days why not
and then when you do sleep you sleep for
how long
uh maybe a few days to a few hours i do
a long sleep i do a sleep i pass out i
don't sleep till i pass out what's the
longest you've slept straight 14 hours
but like you know what i mean
14 hours as long as i've ever slept
mostly it's like a seven to nine hours
sleep like i sleep a lot because i have
nothing to do i'm lucky i have no job or
um nothing to keep me no wife or kids or
anything like me
do it on the side i've had sex in
[ __ ] months
but that's not important i'm sorry and
when you do have sex who do you have sex
with men sometimes women i know
i'm a little kinky but also a little
romantic but mostly
people out here do not know how to have
sex i don't care if you're ugly stop
like showing me your junk and ask me to
put it in my mouth this weird fallacious
obsession that poor men have men of
certain social class have an obsession
with fellatio solution takes about 10 to
20 minutes to produce anything [ __ ]
three minutes you know what i mean they
just [ __ ] me you know what i mean it's
not like rape me but rough [ __ ] me with
women this is hours of making out in
[ __ ] because i'm barely a husband and
i'm like a lipstick lesbian and
what do you describe yourself as are you
a crossdresser are you a transgender i
consider myself a woman but
unfortunately due to my fact that i'm
homeless and have no resources
i can't afford the scissors to chop my
dick off and i can't even afford two
dollars for a [ __ ] razor mark i'm not
gonna stop my tips because i'm not lying
to anyone
you know so i'd rather consider myself a
woman but for now it's call me a [ __ ]
i'm not a drag queen because they work
for what they do they're a different
thing call me a [ __ ] considering
myself i called you a crossdresser in
the last video you didn't call me across
this and people commented in the video
but you were right because i looked like
a crosstalk you had a big yeah a full
beard i had a full beard i still have a
photo it's hard to call you a drink it's
hard to call me a transgender because i
have a beard because mark i can't afford
these razors and honestly shaving takes
about 10 minutes there's nothing that
i'm gonna do more than two minutes i
couldn't put a final shirt on you you
would have been a lumberjack i've been a
lumberjack boy i'd have been well not
kurt cobain but maybe um
i would have been like uh i know lucas
about i don't know how have you been
what have you been up to mark how's
mississippi
i've been uh doing the same thing i do
all the time down here nice that you
work i wish i had a job it's just
i don't do my new labor
so i mean where do you see your life
going from here you've been down here
for you've been on the street how long
who's hiring i just don't have an id i
knew that you would get a job you think
you'd be able to hold the job if i could
get a job i'd hold a job i don't know
how to get a job mark i don't actually
know how to pay bills i'm dropping those
jeans so i don't know how to do this
[ __ ] how old are you i'm 23.
you're 23 yeah i'm 23. i was one august
4th 1997.
yeah sometimes since i was about 15.
it's the only time it's just so hard to
actually done
i mean this is just a system
it's like living in the suburbs
to get an apartment out here i saw all
this the amount of people working work
didn't easy question if you could do
anything and be a fashion designer or
something
i'd be a magazine editor that would be
my ideal job let's say an intern i'll
fetch coffee for crew north politician i
mean they have the [ __ ] the vogue
building the khan and nafta building
it's in the worst area ever it's right
by the altman i have a story there i was
once sleeping out there and about seven
hours into my sleep bouncer comes up to
me and just wake me up all right [ __ ]
i'm in fashion what are you doing to me
he's like why do you see me run over and
get away and i attempted to punch him
and i'm just basically greased his
tongue
i have a good punch i didn't mean punch
i'm not violent person but i just like
get away from your annoying me i'm
sleeping
so i want to go work this woman needs to
love she works on vogue she does she's a
west coast editor i have to work there
because i like working with celebrities
i wish that conan has to move their
offices here because it doesn't make
sense they're in new york but it's an
economic capital some opportunity like
that came up would you clean up and get
your i do everything i sell the soul
almost i do everything i literally sit
there and pluck each weird hair if i can
just literally fetch coffee for them for
about ten dollars a day
fyi this is the love of where i'm at in
life mark i have no accessibility to
anything i'm a real social pariah here
i'm a hermit or some [ __ ] i don't know
why society choosing this way it's not
my fault people are really rude and
cruel to me considering
this is the way they are people always
like they call me a father call me
chinese
go away go away i'm like why is that you
so [ __ ] homophobic they're just
saying i'm a [ __ ] i'm a gay guy what's
wrong with you guys
well i was annoying because i got drugs
in west hollywood it's one strip with 10
clubs
and it's like all these big houses so
it's easy for me to make money there but
i can't get drugs
so
why do i get a party without drugs and
i'm going to college dance at the club
they always let me the avalon plays the
best music i like sir they do some show
[ __ ] i like west hollywood i'm
unfortunate that utopia of a strip mall
of clubs is lay i'm embarrassed
i went to the viper room mark but you
know what they wouldn't let me into the
chateau marmot
they were trying to get a meal at night
because they would not like gaston
i met lindsay lohan there once she was
sweet but a little stale
yeah you're hanging out in the right
neighborhoods
i'm trying to make something happen kid
rose is honestly the best place in life
at the end of the day mark why because
in the business you got to be in the
business doing business you need to have
id
some sort of you know
it goes here right
anything goes here sure let's call it
that it's just accessible to me and for
my clothes i put my water i can put my
food everything else it's like walking
through a wasteland but if you're
walking around west hollywood all day
all night the worst one is beverly hills
oh yeah because it's about a three hour
walk to get anywhere because all houses
i'm going out there looking at houses i
love that what's the worst thing that's
happened to you living on the street
um i'm getting maybe raped-ish not even
doesn't happen honestly it's like
someone comes and punches me or just
watching something this happens some guy
hit me with an umbrella the worst thing
that ever happened to me was eight
months ago i was hit in the head with a
metal pipe because i tried to steal
someone's clothes swallowed by their
clothes and they found me and i walked
around venice beach for an hour bleeding
out of my head no one did anything
but i was okay i couldn't feel anything
i was so high
bleeding on my [ __ ] head
no one did a thing good for them bougie
[ __ ]
eventually uh
i was this is the whole time trying to
find a dress because when you're in that
state you're like
i survive off clothes mark what's
powerful this is fun clothes drugs food
water
everything else
so i'm very lucky that i'm so
self-sufficient i used to be such a part
of your girl but
people here are so like cute to
themselves to like phoenix i've been so
conservative here but this tom died in
2009
i don't know i missed paris floating in
that life you know demi moore
melanie griffiths
it's okay it'll it'll bounce back dear
friendship came out with a new movie
called manchester united's david french
movie
maybe the first movie is goner
it's not one of my favorite movies
because i'm very artsy because i have a
hollywood movie it's gone girl
it's
the most beautiful rebecca can i buy you
some food so maybe we can use buttons
we can get some food here
honey it's on a date just talk to me i'm
so lonely but at the end of the day i
think you should be so sweet too man
you are the most subsidies that i have
received out here on the street because
people are poor
people are poor i give you a brokerages
and rich people don't give up money
you don't do that when i had money
why would i go up to a place and get the
money that's so weird you're laying on
the floor
maybe if you get some food you'll come
down a little bit
maybe
you're gonna be the one i'm worried
about you mark i'm doing this because
this is the most anything i've had in
days
i love your pose it's kind of like you
remind me of brook shields like calvin
klein odd
fine
all right rebecca all right thank you
for visiting me again thank you mark is
that it oh wow that was easy today short
but sweet
hi
rebecca why welcome back welcome i thank
you how are things today is just was it
yesterday you were here david horrible i
think it was like three days ago three
four days ago
yeah terrible terrible what happened
awful i was attacked last night by a man
sexually
ugh i was with you skid row was like
four in the morning
and this guy came at me
and he was on a bike
and he like he comes out he grabs my ass
and like i didn't know what do you think
like smackdown get the [ __ ] away from me
and uh
and um
it's like in one of the alley airways
like maybe like maybe like a mile or two
from here
and uh
he's disgusting his most disgusting
[ __ ] man i was like 45 years old or
some [ __ ] black fat guy he looks like
like a fat dj mustard or something
and uh
and he's like baby what the [ __ ] wrong
with you come on baby come on baby i'm
like i'm not your [ __ ] baby he's like
oh [ __ ] you're a dude i'm like well
thank you sir but i am maybe a woman to
someone and you know all that [ __ ] shot
should i do so while i was sitting there
trying to my [ __ ] he grabbed the [ __ ]
you guys like you guys like everybody's
like guy on the [ __ ] arm like no he
pulls out his [ __ ] let's get on the
[ __ ] god i'm like no so that he's got
the [ __ ] knife on me i'm about to get
stabbed and he's like suck my [ __ ]
dick i'm like no so he literally shoves
me on the ground like shoves the bike
down
shoves me down on the ground [ __ ]
bends me over and then i'm like what and
then he's like on top of me but like
like concentration camps like jack star
and then like oh
then five minutes we just sit in there
going like waiting
and waiting this is out in the open
yes but like not too open it's like
like you know the side streets here it's
exciting
where the warehouses are yeah no traffic
no traffic see people don't stop like
i'm screaming like a [ __ ] you know what
i mean but once it's inside you're like
it's over
it's over you know
yeah it must be horrible to deal with
now i don't i don't care it was just so
in the way and he stole he saw
everything i had i had some really
pretty [ __ ] and i'm is i'm more lost on
the on the goods
stole my purse
okay i found this [ __ ] i found sex
with trashcan
and
there was mud on the floor so i have mud
on me now like i smell disgusting i want
to shower or
i don't want to hug right now i don't
even touch me but like
it's just it's the process it's not even
the thing you know what i mean i'm fine
with trauma i'm not traumatized it's
just there are so many mechanics
involved
but i think you must be traumatized at
some point
do i have to be do i have to it gets in
the way well i think you just you always
discount the the effect that the street
life has on you and i wonder if you
don't get tired of this lifestyle of
course i do but it's it's there it's
convenient what am i gonna say oh i want
uh where's my knight in shining armor
where is my evt card i don't know of
course i'm tired of this at the same
time i love it too much i'm sick
of
the elements of it that are you know
what i mean like if i would complain
i complain of like i'm sick of having to
be harassed i'm sick of having to wait
to like the process of begging people
for money
i'm sick of having to be made to be a
pariah i'm sick of being having to be a
victim i don't want to be a victim
but i have to be
is it my fault sure i'm the one who's
out here you know what i mean
like when i i'll go to the sro do you
know how many months it takes for a star
to get you placed
i'll go to the ebt office do you know
how many weeks it takes to [ __ ]
you know like and then why
and then what you know it was just ah
this is a good sign that you're getting
tired of this life is it i wouldn't say
something i think it is i want it to be
but and then what oh i'm gonna put in
the work to get a job i really would
mark
it's just there's a lot of issues
involved it's mainly identification it's
really hard for me to get an id because
it's impossible to get an id shoved out
here
like i don't know where they don't do
fingerprint scanners so i don't have to
go all the way back to new york just to
get identification that's literally it
by the way pretty much but you know if i
would say that's the one thing that like
sets them away
that's about it
so rebecca you were telling me just a
second ago about your childhood yes so i
was born in paris and i lived in paris i
was about three
and my dad worked for the unesco so he
got an assignment to go work in cairo in
egypt
like doing like um excavation for the
egyptian government so like i grew up
really rich really [ __ ] rich
oil money i don't want to say my last
name and um
so we went we used to live in a mansion
huge mansion in egypt and like the
suburbs and i lived until i was about 14
when i was 14 um i got kicked out of
school and my parents sent me to a
boarding school in england it was called
rochester independent college and i used
to be like a real heavy druggie i just
do a lot of coke when i was a teenager
like i've been rehabbed like four times
swear on my soul
swear on my soul this is the truth and
um so my parents sent me to rehab and
then i got like get kicked in and out of
here and then you have like glasgow type
[ __ ] so they sent me to a boarding
school in england for a year
um and i wouldn't stop drinking
so the day of my exams my they're called
gcses
i fell asleep i wouldn't study i just go
sleep in my exams so i got kicked out
and then um they sent me again to rehab
for a bit and then i lived at home from
like 15 to about 17
and then when i was 18
my dad had moved to america because he
had some business here
so i went to go live with him right
um
in boston boston massachusetts and then
he got me an apartment in brookline
at 34 thatcher street literally 34th
racquet street uh sub-level unit it was
really shitty like cheap like real
old-school apartment see my dad's like
you know like distant fathers when
you're rich like your father's over
there like mr x and the nine diaries so
he was never home you know what i mean
so he just got me an apartment and
ditched me and then he moved to like i
can't remember he said somewhere in
dubai or something you know what i mean
he had business there he's a businessman
and then between america
um
so i got bored and i was like i want to
go on the road and be a hippie you know
i met these bum kids i was like i want
to be a hippie so i went to new york for
like a month and i did that and it was
weird for me because new york is the
type of city where you do that you know
it was just the closest one it was like
like a four hour bus ride
and i'll never forget i bought three
suitcases worth of clothes and not a
camera i used to do photo shoots like on
my own i'll show you my instagram did i
show you my instagram i'll show you my
instagram yeah at an instagram we do
fashion shoots on my own i got no likes
and i went there with three suitcases in
my camera my first day there
i got mugged dude
i stole my camera and my wallet and my
id
and one of my bags are closed so i'm
walking around new york for hours with
two bags of clothes i don't know what to
do in my life
so this woman bought me a meal i was
like hmm are you telling me
did you just sit there you're so sad
people give you money
it's like hmm so i tried it out i got a
hundred dollars i was like ooh
and then i lost one of the other
suitcases so i was down to one suitcase
of clothes
mostly dresses gowns and stuff to go
through shopping and then i spent about
a month living on those clothes and
doing that about a month and i was like
i don't want to be a homeless person i'm
sick last year for me she's like fine
i'll go back to boston
i went back to boston
but i didn't have my credit card and i
couldn't afford a phone
so i could call my dad to get the
[ __ ] id back i lost his number and he
doesn't have a facebook or an email or
anything he's so old school
so my electricity all cut off my gas got
cut off everything that's cut off my
lights my water my toilet was clogged i
don't know how to do any of these things
i don't even know how to wipe a floor so
imagine like living in a [ __ ] [ __ ]
stain there's like pots and pans
everywhere [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere i'm
like
so i left and literally just walked out
of my life and walked into this i went
back to new york so then after that i
went to new york
and i met these voodoo people i lived
with them for a bit um and we used to
practice in the street they're all
homeless and they're all these homeless
witches and they're just practicing and
that's what i learned there was a girl
scout on steak and shook me under her
wing
and she did everything everyday she can
give me makeup she needs cigarettes and
drugs um and on my birthday i'll never
forget this this china came up to me and
she was like um this first time i didn't
ever do anything nice for me she's like
are you hungry she was in mcdonald's i'm
like it's my birthday so she took me to
stonewall the club
and um
and she had a collection for me 40 bucks
and they played rihanna for me it was
the best night of my life marcus i ever
felt being home was the first time i
ever felt anyone cared about me you know
what i mean it's the first time i never
had friends growing up what about your
parents your family dude they suck like
really reserved really strict really
strict and my mother was very physically
abusive very physically abusive
she pulled me by my hair
like [ __ ] i'd be bleeding and you
couldn't tell anyone i'm gonna go to
school and be like do you have siblings
one younger brother i've been in therapy
like my whole life i grew up like it is
a direct you know it is a direct easy
start right i'm the editor of
homelessness
good for me
so that's your life story well yes but
with a dick on top
and then you came to l.a i came up no no
no no no no no first i went to new
orleans virginia
miami la sox
virginia raves new orleans oh my god
so much food
so many parties
so many things happen you don't pay for
anything
and in new orleans you have like all
these witches they live in squats and
you get 50 bucks a month and you're
living with all these [ __ ] bum
witches miami
started as follows my first day there i
meet a woman she goes here yeah maya
she's a goddess
she gives me a phone five oranges and a
pack cigarettes
a week later i wake up on the beach
a man wakes me up with a line of coke
some french toast sticks in his penis
and then i broke into um
you're not wearing any underwear i don't
know where mark i'm homeless
where is underwear mark excavating for
clothes and trash cans
is not necessarily a practical way to
live your life so underwear it's not
really a commodity i know that but but
it's is it your own no what happened
it's like
we're gonna have well you gotta yeah
right right you're doing that up right
you're saying you're doing like a fusion
makeup i figured out i was trying to
seduce you mark i'm being a little coy
it was snl skate rebecca it's just
called rebecca christian wig she's like
oh my god
i like blondes but not with beards how
dare you buy me a razor daddy
what am i caitlyn jenner bougie [ __ ]
i'm homeless
and then you eventually came to l.a
you're standard yes and then i came out
like two years ago and i went to venice
beaches where there's like clawey gown
and then i got today oh
they live like that there it's perfect
it's all ten incompetents all these
weirdos
i met somebody turned out like she's a
witch where's your brother
probably like school somewhere let's not
discuss it just because my family have a
name i don't wanna say the name but it's
a name
leave it there
it's not important i don't i'm not
making an impression i'm not trying to
be like oh no okay
i know you're a little bit in your story
uh
let's just say where i'm this my brother
is my my duel he's like suit and tie and
yes sir and go to work for the family
and he's that you know what i mean like
i used to be the
i was the gifted child and then i became
bad so he's become he's like um the good
little boy like imagine like i'm gonna
go work for daddy's company that's him
i'm not gonna do that [ __ ]
500 million dollars
the [ __ ] are you gonna do with that if
all you do all day is sit at a [ __ ]
desk
telling people what to do get a [ __ ]
from his secretary no mark i'm into men
i'm gay i'm not going to pretend to be
straight
for anything
until next time
mr demille
why am i so anyway
i know i am but what are you
no you're good